je suis boba fett
laissé pour mort dans le désert de
tataouine
diab a régné par la peur
j'ai l'intention de renier avec respect
je ne suis pas chasseur de primes
on m'a dit le contraire
je sais que vous siégez sur le trône de
votre ancien employeur
tu as baraigne par la peur
j'ai l'intention de renier avec respect
vous étiez jadis capitaine aux ordres de
jabba net je viens vous faire une
proposition mutuellement avantageuse
[Musique]
pourquoi parler de conflit quand la
coopération peut tous nous rendre riche
qu'est ce qui nous empêcherait de vous
tuer
prendre tout ce qu'on souhaite
si vous aviez montré autant d'insolence
envers jabba il vous aurait fait dévorer
par sa petite ménagerie je vous en prie
parler librement